で そこで前説明したこの時間の問題
行為はすぐその場で結果出さなくても
後でゆっくりとじわじわと結果出すこともできるんです
で あの お湯を沸かそうと思って
やかんにいっぱい水を入れて
我々は一回だけガスコンロに火をつける
それで十五分経っちゃうと
もうお湯は沸かしてるんです
十五分間も火をつける必要はないんです
だから水に熱を上げますという一回の行為で
その水は自分の法則によってゆっくりと温めて沸騰するんです
ですから このどこら辺取っても原因結果なんですけど
適当なところで我々はもう取るんです
例えば水が沸騰しています
誰がやったかというと
火をつけた人の責任になるんです
そこで科学的に説明して水が沸騰しているのは
もうちょっとこの百度のに温かく温かくなってる水にさらに熱を上げたんだから
このさらにのさらに上げた熱量がもっと分子の間をね
広げて もう蒸気にしているんだとかね
そんなことを言ったっても大して意味がないんです
それは別に間違ってることじゃないんです
沸騰するっていうことは
百度まで熱が上げたところで
さらに熱を上げると あの水の分子の間が空けちゃうんです
分子は分子が激しく動いて互いに分かれちゃいますね
それに我々は蒸気になってもう出ていくんだと言うんです
それは事実なんですけど
ですから 沸騰したことの一番短い原因は
その百度ぐらいに温めてる水に入ったあの熱量なんですね
でもそこまできめ細かく考えなくても
誰が沸かしたんですか？で言えば
あのガスコンロに火をつけた人の責任になるんです
そこでは人殺しの場合も同じ
例たくさん出ていて 例えば鉄砲を撃って人を殺す
その場で死んじゃうんです
あるいはもうトラックでも運転して人をもう踏みつけちゃうと
その行為をやった瞬間で人を死んじゃうんです
でも今何かして十年後にその人を死ぬようにすることもできるんです
まあ例えば人を殺そうと思って
その人の頭をぶん殴ったと
そこでその人はその場で死ななかったと
怪我はしたんだけど まあ例えば頭蓋骨を割れちゃったり
いろいろなことになって
まあ病院に行って治ってもらったと
でもそこで小さな骨の 1片が
まあ見えないレントゲンでも見えない骨のひとかけらが脳細胞に入ったって言います
そこでそこはもうストレスになっちゃいますから
細胞に 脳の中の腫瘍とかね
がんが出てきたんだと
出てきて十五年経ったところで
どんどんどんどん脳の中にがんが出てきて
それ手術もできないし
その人は死んじゃうと
そうすると あの殴った人のせいなんです
お医者さんにバレなくたって
お医者さんもさっぱりわからない
なんで脳の中でがんが出たかということを
殺された人も死んでいく人もわからないかもしれません
でも殴った人は殺そうと思って殴ったんだから
その原因で死んだとなんだから
その人は殺人なんです
そういう風にその場で死ななかったんだからということは
もうあまり考えてないんです
時間ずれてもしょうがないと
そこで人のことをね 怒って
本当に嫌な人だと殴らなくちゃいけないんだと思って
野球バットで頭を殴ったと
殴ったところで その人はあまりも強烈に殴られたんだからもう死んでしまったと
でも殴った側がただ殴ってやるという気持ちだけでしたし
殺そうという気持ちはなかったんですね
とことん痛い目にあわせてやるということで殴ったと
でもそれでその人死んじゃっても殴った人は殺人じゃないんです
殺す気持ちはなかったんだから
ですから 法律でどうかっていうことは関係ないんです
仏教で考えているのは
その行為をする人の気持ち
で 病院の人が点滴を受けているんだと
そこで栄養とか何とか入ってるでしょうね
そこで看病する人がね
もうたくさん栄養入った方がその人は早く治るんではないかなと思って
点滴が体に入る量があるんですね
それをちょっと増やしておくんだと
そこでそれが体にずっと入ってしまっちゃって
血圧が変わっちゃって
体の温度も変わっちゃって
どうせ体弱いんだから
その人は心臓発作を起こして死んだかもしれません
でもそれで調べたところで
もう誰かがこの点滴の機械をいじったっていうことを発見しても
その人は仏教から見れば殺人にはならないんですね
その人は無知なんですけど
それで自分の考え方で栄養が入ったら元気になるんだったら
もう早く入った方がいいんじゃないかなと
ですから 自分の気持ちとしては人を早く治してほしいという気持ちだからね
そういうのは悪意はなかったんだから
罪にはならない そこで病院側が自分の医療ミスで自分に訴えられた
大変だからそれで徹底的に調べて
それをこの人がもう殺したそうとか何とか言って
それでもういろいろその人を殺人罪で法律で捕まえても
それは別なことであって
もうその人は殺人ではないんです
そういうことを言ったのは
この心の気持ち自体が業であるということを考えてほしいということなんです
そういうわけで自分に回しちゃうんですね
我々の心が瞬間瞬間変わっちゃいますけど
今の心が死んで次の心が生まれるんですね
だから次の心が現れる原因は前の心なんですよ
というわけで カルマから逃げられない
我々 私 私というのは結局心にまず私と言うし
すごく体が痛いというと
そこに心が働いているんだから
中に住んで痛いと言うし
楽しいという場合は心の中に生まれる感情がですから
その感情に私と言う 結局私というのは心なんです
ただ 心っていうのは随分変化していくんです
変化していくんだけど
前の心 次の心はコピーする
もうですからまあ逃げられないんです
ですから 人間として見たって
人間の物体を見たっても
最初は一つの細胞で生まれる
一つの細胞でも人間なんです
その細胞はつに割れるでしょうに
分裂するでしょうし その場合は元の細胞のコピーなんですね
だからその分裂したつの細胞は新しい細胞なんですけど
前の細胞の特色やら全部自分で持ってるんです
何か前の細胞から確実に行くわけじゃないんです
細胞分裂を見るとなんか行くように見えるんですけど
なぜならばこの染色体なんかつに割れるでしょ
割れるんだけど 本当はそうでもないんです
染色体も取ってっちゃうんです
ですから 新しい物質を入れて
ちゃんと DNA のこの螺旋が新しいものを作っちゃうんです
古いものを壊れるんです
ですから 一つの細胞が次の細胞になっちゃったら
こちらから半分あるかもしれませんだけど
その細胞は次の細胞になると
あっちから行った半分はもう消えてるんです
新しく入った半分で残ってるんですね
そこら辺は私は別に明確に説明する必要ないと思いますけどね
だから DNA の半分が新しい細胞に行くでしょう
そこで残り半分が新しい物質で作っちゃうんです
そこでその細胞のこの古い DNA の半分がすぐに壊れちゃう
壊れて新しい物質で新しい DNA が作っちゃうんです
そこで回分裂しちゃうと全く新しい細胞なんですね
まあ質的には全く新しい
でも細胞分裂しながら元の細胞をコピーしていっちゃうでしょうに
DNA の構造っていうのはコピーしていくんだから
もうどうしようもないんですね
最初に出てきた細胞のプログラムで死ぬまでやらなくちゃいけない
ですから この そう似ているような働きが心にも起こるんです
心はつ消えると新しい心が生まれるんだけど
その心は前の心のコピーなんです
コピーだから全く同じものではない
どんどん変化していく
そういうことで 何か行為をしたならば
そのインプレッションですか
そのやったことのインプレッションと言えば
日本語風に言えば何でしょうかね
何か跡をつくんですね
心に何かやったらそれなりのエネルギーの跡が作っちゃうんです
その跡は次から次へと続けちゃうんです
英語では大体インプレッションという言葉は大変
何かインプレッション送っちゃうんですね
心に 印象 まあインプレッションは印象ですけどね
でもインプレッションはこの専門用語として使っちゃうと
印象はちょっと使いにくいですね
日常生活の英語で使ってるインプレッションではないんです
で これそれもちょっとした専門用語なんで
まあ何かの形とか何とか
まあ跡みたいなものは残っちゃう
まあポテンシャルみたいなエネルギーってですね
そういうのは心に残っちゃうんですね
何かこういう何かしたら
やっぱりまあ私たちもそうですよ
なんかやっちゃったら
なんか心の中でなんか残るでしょうね
それはゆっくりと消えますけど
消えるものもあって 消えないものもある
例えばずっと分ぐらい人と喋っても
その人帰った瞬間でさっと心が元に戻りますかね
戻らないんです あのインプレッションであのもう押さえられちゃって
ある時間ずっとあって
ゆっくりとそれが消えていっちゃうんです
そこでずっと消えないインプレッションも出てきてちゃうんですね
インプレッションという私が使っている言葉は
この IMPRESS というこの言葉から使っている言葉な IMPRESS というのはこの
プレスということは知ってますね
何か押すという意味で
印刷屋さんにはプレスというんですね
英語で 印刷屋さんというのはプレス
インプレス インという言葉を入れたら
もうちょっと強い意味なんです
わざとプレスしたと わざと印刷したんだと
そういう風なインプレスなんですね
ですから たまにある行為は心にインプレスされちゃったら
もうその後は消えないんですね
英語もよく考えちゃうと複雑ですね
インプレッションという何か画
絵の種類もあるでしょ
印象派とか何とかインプレッショニストとかね
あれとそういう違うんです
そういうことで 我々この心でやることっていうのは
瞬間瞬間やることを何でもインプレスしますけど
全部残るわけじゃないしね
まあ消えちゃうし 何の影響もないようなものもたくさんあるし
でも忘れられないものもまたその中であっちゃうんです
この忘れられないものはもう大変気をつけなくちゃいけない
ですから 例えばひどいインプレッション
インプレッションが入っちゃったら
それで一生悩む人々いるでしょうね
例えば小さい時は親にいじめられたと
そこでインプレッションが残っちゃったら
その人一生それで悩んだりする
で まあ親にいじめられたわけじゃないんだけど
大変愛情いっぱいで育てられたんだけど
もうある日親にぶたれて怪我しましたとことがあっても
それはインプレッション残らない
もしかすると後でそれは面白く思い出すかもしれませんしね
自分がよく悪いことをやったんだからね
もうその時はもう母親殴られていまだにその傷痕があるんだよとか自慢にする可能性もありますし
ですから その時の状態によってね
そういうことで この道徳的な世界だからね
まあ人を騙したりしちゃうと
そういうインプレッションは消えない
人を殺したりすると そのインプレッションというのはもう消えない
忘れることはできない
一時的に忘れてもパッと浮かんだりするんですね
そういう風にカルマ それは業であってカルマであります
いいこともそうで いいことをしたらそのインプレッションは消えませんしね
[沈黙]で 仏教では業っていうのは簡単にわかりやすくするためにこう言ってるんですね
人は行為をする場合は
やっぱり行為したいんだから行為しているんです
したいんだからやるものは全部行為であって
カンマですよ 業です まず一人一人
で 横になりたいと思って横になることは行為で
業であって で 何か自分が立っていたものを壊れちゃって
自分が横に倒れたことは業ではないんです
自分でやった行為じゃないんだから
虫を殺したいと思って手で叩いたら
それは行為であって殺生であって
ただ机叩いてやろうと思ったところで
机を叩いたという行為はある
業があるんだけど そこで虫が死んじゃってもそれは関係ないんですね
たまたま運が悪い虫がそこに入っただけのことです
そこでこの何かしたいという気持ち
その気持ちを 2つに分けて貪瞋痴で行動するか
不貪不瞋不痴で行動するかと
貪瞋痴でする行動は全部悪い業で
悪業で 不貪不瞋不痴でする行為は全部善行為ですね
善業です そこで善と悪が分けられます
善と悪が分けられるのは貪瞋痴の尺度で分けられるわけです
まあカルマってのはそれぐらいで理解しておけばいいんです
意志は業であると やりたい気持ちは業であると
この気持ちは貪瞋痴の気持ちだったら悪いことをやる
不貪不瞋痴の気持ちだったらいい行動だと
悪いことをしたら悪い結果が出てくるんだと
いいことをしたらいい結果が出てくるんだ
そこでわからないのは
この必ずしも悪いこと
悪い結果 いいこと いい結果というふうに言いにくいところなんですね
ガラスに石を投げたならば
必ずしも割れるよと言えませんだから
そこでいろんな問題が出てくる
例えば人が 子供が嘘を言って人を騙しちゃった
そこで騙された側やらみんなすごく怒って
まあそういうことをやった人にはちゃんともう厳しく罰と言うんですか
まあ罰せなくちゃいけないと決めると
決めて まあ探して 誰ですかと
その子供見つかっちゃう
見つかったところで その子供はすごい可愛くて
もう見たところですぐ愛情が生まれちゃうんだ
そうすると この子供叱っていろいろひどい目に合わせたったらね
この子供は将来性は良くないんだと思っちゃうでしょう
で まあそういうことで
まあいいわと で 罰することは何もなくて
もう帰る可能性もあります
で もう違う例で言うならばね
例えば自分が自分の部屋で勉強している
先生 隣の部屋でなんかガタガタガタガタガタガタガタガタ音する
それすごい邪魔 で どんどんどんどん苛立ってくる
今やめるか 今やめるかで迷っているんだけど
やめるところがどんどんあれも大きくなっていっちゃう
そこですごく怒って もうぶん殴ってやると
邪魔だよと言って部屋開けてみたら
小さな赤ちゃんが何かおもちゃを持ってなんとか遊んでると見つかる
それで音が鳴っていた
全部それであれ消えちゃうでしょうに
ですから この人に邪魔したのは悪いと言ったっても
その赤ちゃんにはそれなりに悪い結果が出たわけじゃないんです
ですから 原因 因果法則抜きにして業の説明はできない
だからお釈迦様は普通の行為論と業論というのは一緒にして置いておくんです
というわけで 人を殺したんだからといって確実に不幸になるということは決められない
その人をちょっと工夫して
そこからもうなんか抜けることもできるんですね
それに必要なのは知恵なんですけどね
それなりに知恵使っちゃうと
なんとか抜けることもできるし
知恵がない人が大した業でもなくてもすごい悪い結果が得られるし
そういうことをお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
小さなろくな罪もしてないんだけど
地獄に落ちる人々もいて
大胆な罪を起こしてるんだけど
地獄に落ちない人々もいるんだと
そういうわけで この悪因悪果
善因善果という風なこの大乗仏教の表現は
そのまま初期仏教で出てこないんです
厳密に言えば 悪因には悪果しかないし
善因には善果しかないんですが
実際に結果が出る時はいろんな原因ごちゃ混ぜになってどうなるかっていうことはまたわからない
だいたい業っていうのは基本的にそれぐらいで覚えておけばいいんです
貪瞋痴の行為は悪いカルマであって
不貪不瞋痴の行為はいいカルマである
それから業っていうのは一応それで説明は終わりますけど
これからテキストに入ります
テキストの番目のカテゴリー
ちょっと時間経ちますので
皆さんは疲れているかもしれません
ちょっと分ぐらい休憩して始まります
という言葉を教えてもらいましたけど
刻印 何か刻印 何か行動したら
それ心に残すという 刻印ってどんな漢字で書くんですかね
刻むと  そういう そういう
刻む 因は印刷する 因果の
因果  印刷の印  いや 業をいろんなカテゴリーに分けています
つのカテゴリーに分けてます
一つまたさらにつに分けて種類あります
で 業でだいたい誰でも一番仏教でも気になるのは
この我々の生まれること
この世で生まれたのは
もう何か心の中に刻印されている過去の何かエネルギーなんですね
それでこの世の中で最初の心を決めちゃうんですね
心のエネルギーと状態
で それで死ぬまで その人の運命は何らかの形で左右されるんですね
そういう生まれに関するつがあります
1番目はジャナカ そういう 4種類あります
それはつも生まれに関するんです
で ジャナカ・カンマっていうのは
こちらのテキストに日本語の言葉がありますから
こちらの冷静業と書いてますけどね
ジャナカ・カンマっていうのは
我々に生まれが作ってくる業なんですね
で この世の中で死んだらまたどこかに生まれるんです
そのどこかに生まれるのは
その業に冷静業と言うんです
ジャナカ・カンマと言うんです
で こういう風に考えてみてください
例えば人が生きてて 最後に死ぬ時になる
死ぬ間際になったら まあ頭はもうすごい強烈に勢いで働き始めるんです
それはみんな心が弱いと思いちゃいますけど
弱くはないんです その人はすごい強烈なんです
体が弱いんです 死ぬ時だから体が弱ければ弱いほど
心がもう勝手に行動し始めちゃうんですね
で 今我々は体に抑えられて体の速さで考えているんです
体っていうのは結局遅いんです
で 体がどんどん悪くなってくると
機能しなくなってくると
心はもう別に遠慮なしに行動しちゃうんです
で それあの高熱が出た時
すごく熱が出たら もう人には立っていられないんですね
そこで あるいは何か薬でも飲んで
もう体を動かない状態にして
もうもう寝ていると その時ありとあらゆること幻覚
見えるはしゃべるは まあいろんなことをやっているでしょうに
高熱の時は その時 本人にとっては心弱いという感じは全くないんです
で 外から見ている人は高熱だから余計なこと言ってるんだ
ああだこうだとかね 言うかもしれませんだけど
その本人がの心が強烈に自分が寝ているということはわからない
どこかに行っているはとか
誰かと喧嘩しているとか
誰かと喋っているとか
まあ見たこともない いろんな幻覚やらもう見えるとか
強烈に心が活動している
それは心がちょっと機能しなくなっちゃったんだから
その分で心じゃなくて体が機能しなくなっちゃったんだから
その分心がもう自分勝手に行動することになるんです
同じ状態なんです 死ぬ時も
死ぬ時はもう体は死ぬということはもう最高に悪い状態なんですね
体にとっては ですからもうもう心はそれっきりで遠慮しない体に
ですから死ぬ時は 例えば体あちこち痛くたっても関係ない
そんなもんは 体の一部なくなった
そんなもう気にしない
自分で行動する 体健康的なので
ちょっと怪我しただけでもそれすごい気になる
どうしようか この怪我はとか
でも死にかけてる人々はもう足を取ろうか
もう内臓はお医者さんが取ってやろうか
もういろんな機械入れようか
別に気にしないでしょう
ですから まあ我々と喋れません
なぜならば口があまり動かないんだから
人が来たっても目は開けてあったっても見ていない
なぜならば体がもうほとんど壊れているんだから
だから私たちにコンタクトできないんだから
その人が意識は弱いと今は喋れませんと
と勝手にこちら判断するだけで
本人の心は強烈な勢いで活動しているんです
それは本当かないかというと
やっぱり死にかけてる人に聞くしか方法ないです
[笑い]そこで気だって問題はもう喋れないんですね
その体が機能しない状態だから
でも私たちにも日常茶飯事で同じ経験があるでしょうに
体が全く動かない状態になった時は心はどうですかと
心は動く動くは もうものすごい妄想する
暴走するんです その時は
本当ないような状態で
でもその暴走する状態はまだ遅いんです
それでも体に依存しているんだから
もっと早いんです 心 体に頼れなければないほど
心が強烈に早くなっちゃうんです
そういうことで 死ぬ瞬間でも心は暴走し始めちゃうんです
我々の言葉で言うならば
人間の言葉で言うならば
心は暴走し始めちゃうんですね
その時 なんとかのこの今までのやったことやら
この消えてない何かインプレッションが出てきて
そちらの幻覚が現れちゃうんです
そちらにふさわしい 幻覚が現れたら
まあどうせ人は悟ってないんだから
執着あるんだから その幻覚に囚われるんです
囚われることは避けられないんです
皆様にもすっごい綺麗な音楽を流してしまったら
ものすごい綺麗だから
綺麗な音楽やと思っちゃうでしょうね
それ避けられないんです
ものすごい美味しい食べ物をあげて
あげて それ食べた途端
あ 美味しいと感じることは避けられますかね
それを悟ってない人にとっては無理なことなんです
執着しない状態っていうのは
ですから体も弱くなっちゃって
心は暴走している時は
どうしてもその感情は避けられないんですね
ですから 我々は高熱を出て
もう意識がほとんど働かない状態で見るものについては
もうそれは本当でしょうね
その場合は その時怖いことを見たら
ものすごく怖くなるでしょうね
叫ぶでしょう 怖くて もう避けられないんです
執着するんです ですから
死ぬ時もそういう風に心が暴走する
その時インプレッションされた何か刻印されたものが出てきて
何ですかと決まってないんです
そこら辺いい加減なんです
私たち何か思い出す時は
まあ明日はあれを思い出すでしょうと決まりありますかね
ないでしょう 何のことなく
過去のインプレッションされたものを刻印されたものはすぐ思い出すんだから
何の前触れもなく たまに何か前触れがあったりとかありますけどね
何か似ているものを見たところで思い出す時もそれもあります
そうでなくても思い出したりする
ですから 普通の人の次の生まれ変わりはどこかということは
もう決めたもんじゃないんです
分かったもんでもない
で 今までの生き方 あるいはもっと過去世の生き方
どっちでもいいんです
もう心には体が関係なくなっちゃったんだから
心だけの世界だから 過去現在未来心にはないんです
それは皆様ご存知知ってるでしょ？我々は自分の年はいくつかいる
五十二歳ですよって言うかもしれませんだけど
心では何歳ですかと聞いたら全然関係ないんですね
心にとっては 心にとっては私は私ですよと
ずっと 年ないんです それは体に関係があって
私は五十二歳 三歳とか言うんです
ですから 心には時間関係ない
そういうわけで体に頼っていると時間があります
子供の時 あんなことを私はやったんですよ
それは体が子供の時なんです
そこで体から外してもらっちゃえば
心にとってはもう過去っていうのはもうないんです
何でももう一緒ですから
もう何でも思い出せる
全部今なんです そういうわけで
今世でやった今世のインプレッションだけではなくて
遠い遠い昔の過去でも
その場合は体から過去というんです
心に過去がないんです
昔々の体でやったことでも思い浮かぶ可能性ある
で この妄想する瞬間にそこで見たものについてすっごく囚われる
例えば怖いものを見たならば
ものすごい恐怖感でビビっちゃう
恐怖感も執着なんです
面白いことを見たら楽しくてしょうがなくなっちゃう
それも執着なんです 悪いことを思い浮かんだら
ものすごい強烈に浮かぶ
例えば自分が殺生したことがあるんだと
今世ではなくて 過去世ででも過去世でもう戦争に行って
もう大量に人を殺したことがあるんだと
そういうことがあったならば
もう体がもう死にかけているし
体とはもう心関係なくなっちゃったら
これは強烈に直接自分の心の中に再現しちゃうんです
そこでもうそこに囚われる
ああ 楽しいとはその時思わないですね
人を殺されることを見たら
自分人を殺していることを見たら
その時は誰でもものすごい嫌な怒りともう憎しみでやってるんです
いいことを思い出すと
またかえってまた同じですごい強烈にそのインプレッションが幻想を通って幻覚として出てくる
それに囚われる で 囚われて
そのどっちかの瞬間で
その人のこの体から心が離れちゃうんです
いわゆるこの体で心が生まれなくなっちゃうんですね
生まれなくなっちゃったら
次に違うところにこの心はまた活動始めるんです
そこで生まれ変われというんです
ですから 生まれ変わるというのは
確実に人間にならなくちゃいけないとかね
形取らなくちゃいけないということじゃないんです
仏教で生まれ変わるっていうのは
この体で心を最後の瞬間終わったら
次に何の感覚もなく 同じ感覚で次の心が生まれる
今も感覚なく心が生滅変化するんだから
その時も感覚なく死んだ
次に生まれたと ですから
この生まれ変わるということは
決してこの人が死んでどこかで人間として現れたと
それだったらすごい時間取っちゃうんです
そういうことはない 次の瞬間の心に生まれ変わったと言うんです
そういうことで 初期仏教では
初期仏教というよりはテーラワーダ仏教ではこの中間の概念はないんです
中っていうのは 大乗仏教が作った考え方で
人が死んでもう次にしっかりした場所を選ぶまであっちこっちウロウロしているんだと
それは生まれだと言えないんだと
生まれてないとも言えないんだと
もうくだらない いろんな言葉よ
それは色界でもないんだと
無色界でもないんだと
欲界でもないんだと それだったらどこにもないことですけど
まあああだこうだ 一週間いるんだ
四十九日間いるんだ 三ヶ月はいるんだ
いろんなことを言うんだけど
それはもう別にまあ大したことではなくて
単なるこの学的な想像だけなんですね
で テーラワーダで見ているのは
心はある速さで生滅変化していきます
で そのものの生滅変化っていうのはスピードが決まってるんだから
それは誰にもどうすることもできない
で もののスピードだから生滅変化する
例えばこの我々の物体のスピードはありますけど
でも光っていうのは光子だから
光子には自分のスピードがあるんですね
それは減ることもないし
増えることもないんです
光の速度はこれより早くしようと思ったってもできないし
遅くしようと思ったってもできないんです
光はそれをしてだから
それで原子原子見たら原子核の周りにエネルギーの膜があるでしょうね
その膜が回っているスピードはもう決まってて
それは遅くすることもできないし
早くすることもできないんですね
いわゆる基本的な物質にも決まってるスピードあるんです
物質にも で